welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and
what do you say folks you ready for some
non-donald trump news because i know i
sure am
so let's start with this two individuals
adam fox and barry croft are now facing
a maximum of life in prison after a jury
convicted them this week
in their plot to kidnap
michigan governor
gretchen
whitmer
now this plot i'm sure most people
understand and remember what happened
but just in case you didn't you had
these individuals along with several
other right-wing extremists
that became so angry
about governor whitmer's coveted
restrictions
that they began plotting and the fbi
actually had an informant within their
little group a guy called big dan
um big dan
is in there in their little extremist
group where they're plotting
to go and kidnap governor whitmer
from her vacation home
and they had their weapons they were
practicing with explosives
and that's also by the way another
charge that they received but they
they were going to do this they were
going to overthrow
the government of the state of michigan
through this kidnapping plot
this is actually the second time
these two men had been on trial the
first one
resulted in a mistrial
because the jury obviously could not
come to any unanimous decision and the
defense
had done a fairly successful job of
arguing at least successful in terms of
the jury being hung there
of convincing them
that the fbi
set up basically
entrapment
for these individuals the fbi guy big
dan
let's let's not disrespect big dan by
calling him anything else big dan
um
basically working for the fbi convinced
these men to do it
right if big dan hadn't been there
pulling the little puppet strings they
never would have thought about
kidnapping governor whitmer
but this time around of course the the
jury said no you are not making a
convincing case that
big dan is the guy responsible for this
so
they got convicted again they're facing
life in sentence life in prison excuse
me as their sentence at a maximum
now
here's what drives me insane
about this particular story
these men
wanted to kidnap and most likely kill
a democratically elected governor
because of covet
restrictions
that's what this was over that's what
this is about and yes these individuals
had you know expressed anti-government
sentiment on social media for years
which is one of the reasons that the
jury this time didn't buy the fbi
entrapment argument
but this was the last straw like how
dare you
try to take care of people during a
public health emergency the likes of
which we have never seen in modern
america how dare you
tell us to wear masks how dare you
tell us that we have to socially
distance i'm going to kill you
because you don't want me to die
because let's be honest that's what this
was that's what coveted restrictions
were
and we saw it across the country not
kidnapping plots thank god
but we saw these lunatics burning masks
getting children to throw masks into
burning trash cans
protesting over the fact that we don't
want you to die
but apparently that's a bridge too far
for these freaks
like you you can't
want to take care of them you can't want
to protect them
because if you do
they may try to kill you
okay can you wrap your heads around that
for just a moment folks
that's where we're at that's what we
have come to
and of course we're acting like cove
it's not still out there killing a
couple thousand people a week in this
country which it is
we don't have any restrictions anywhere
anymore you're free to do whatever
but you're assuming the risks
and we still have people out there
trashing vaccines
posting misinformation
ranting and raving about non-existent
coveted protection measures because
again they don't exist anywhere anymore
but they're still mad
they're still protesting
they're still acting like oh my god this
is terrible this is tyranny
all because
some lawmakers not even all of them but
just some of them
actually wanted to protect their
constituents and not
let them die from a deadly disease which
at the time of the kidnapping plot we
had no treatments for we had no vaccines
for
we had no way to protect ourselves other
than wearing the masks and socially
distancing and avoiding unnecessarily
large
gatherings
that's all we could do we didn't have
the paxlavit pills
we didn't have vaccines as i said we had
nothing
we were throwing the spaghetti against
the wall when it came to treatment
that's why so many people died
but i guess that's what these
you know extremists would have preferred
let me die
i'd rather die than have to wear a mask
i'd rather kidnap the governor of a
state
than not be able to go to chili's for
drinks after work on friday
that is unfortunately the country that
we live in today